lately we've been talking a lot about
apex legends on this show whether it's
the crazy viewing figures this game gets
or the darker side with this rampant
cheating problem but today we're going
to be taking a look at a character which
some people are saying has destroyed the
entire strategy of the game a broken
character which respawn have recently
tried to fix but which might just be
unfixable
[Music]
all right maybe you play a lot of apex
legends maybe you're completely new to
the game and you want to learn more
about it well either way we've got
videos just like this all the time on
the channel so make sure you're
subscribed to the score esports that way
you'll never miss a video just like this
one cheers
you're an apex legend mate all right
those of you who know apex legends will
probably already know which character
i'm about to talk about it's sir there
was a lot of excitement around his
release a few weeks ago the outcast
visionary who specializes in stalking
and hunting his enemies with the help of
his drones some members of the apex
community were already a bit skeptical
of what the trailer was promising though
that seer looked a lot stronger than
what respawn was suggesting and they
were right he turned out to be the
single most busted legend the game has
ever seen on release some people have
even said he's the most busted character
in the fps genre yeah it's that bad seer
is a character that has caused people to
seriously discuss whether apex should
implement a ban system similar to league
of legends and dota
i don't know what i would want i'd
rather
honestly i think seer might be the
character that that forces a band system
in apex right like in comp i feel like
it's it's absolutely necessary at this
point
and what's even crazier is that
according to some play testers sir
wasn't this broken when they had the
chance to try him out somewhere along
the line respawn decided to mega buff
him before release did you uh did you
play test by the way
no all right
okay okay
i was just wondering if i if she was
that broken in play tests too but what
i've heard from other playtested oh my
god i would not let this character come
out there's no way i've heard from other
people that play tested
that um or like from heard from like
people that play tested
that
apparently
sheer didn't do all that [ __ ] at all he
was completely fine and the place has
like a good character and then they
apparently just omega buffed him before
they released him on monday respawn
released patch notes which among other
things addressed some of the complaints
about sear now a lot of people were
pretty pumped about this with some
people even wishing each other happy
seeing earth day on twitter so what the
hell is going on here well firstly for
those of you that aren't familiar with
apex legends let me explain why this
character has had people threatening to
quit the game so sears passive ability
is heart seeker and if you've ever
played call of duty it's similar to the
heartbeat sensor attachment a small
circle indicates the direction of nearby
enemies if the arrow is blue then
they're nearby and if it's orange then
they're within 75 meters of sear you can
also hear the enemy's heartbeat coming
from one direction which further helps
you pinpoint their location essentially
the passive gives cyr a lot of
information about enemy teams without
much of a cost to himself in fact people
were saying that his passive is
literally stronger than some other
character's ultimates
something ain't right there and even
though it's strong by itself players
quickly realized that his passive is
even more busted than originally thought
all right because you know how you use
his uh heartbeat sensor
and you're kind of slow well here's a
little hack that's probably going to get
nerfed
like i said it's really slow right now
but when you hold your tactical
you hold your tactical you can sprint
dude and get infinite heartbeat sensor
look at this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
dude this this just
this [ __ ] needs to stop so in this new
patch the delay between sensor spikes
for full health targets is going up to
1.75 seconds from 1.25 and the center
circle ellipses are being removed so
that means he won't be able to see
people with his passive as often and it
forces more time investment on seared
players when using it the max detection
range is now just 75 meters and the
sensor's field of view has also been
reduced then we've got sears tactical
ability focus of attention activating it
released a cone-shaped burst which
damages and stuns enemies and also
cancels any abilities they're channeling
such as healing or reviving oh and it's
really loud like really loud
[Music]
the most busted thing about this though
has always been that it outlines enemies
who have been hit by it even through
walls yeah it's basically a wall hack in
conjunction with his passive the ability
to see an enemy including their health
and shields through walls is such a
glaring advantage when compared to other
characters kits
come
and then back and i've got a 1v1
some reason this guy
is on his own
all right we got the information that
the
the um okay we saw all three legends
anyway but we got the information that
octane shields got broke
from that emp charge which means it's
just like another piece of information
that we know
like you just get too much data and it's
a wall hack that also [ __ ] the enemy up
sometimes it's like you're not even
seeing enemies that are ready to fight
back if they've been hit by the cone
then they're going to be stunned
disoriented and possibly just had a
critical ability cancel that they were
trying to pull off apex legends balance
designer john larson summed this up
quite well in a twitter thread where he
explained the rationale behind these
nerfs he said seer tactical used as a
dollar store emp to farm damage and
drain resources was definitely
problematic at high level play plus
looking at your health bar and seeing a
sliver of it missing for taking damage
through walls is a major feels bad
monday's patch attempted to address this
by increasing the detonation delay
slightly and also enemies who are hit by
it are no longer damaged or flashed and
also have their screen shake reduced one
of the other things that really annoyed
people was that cyr could use his q
while moving at full speed this has been
nerfed by adding movement reduction
while holding his stun also the audio of
the burst has been reduced so enemies
will no longer have their eardrums blown
out and then cried themselves to sleep
from the traumatic noise we're not done
yet though let's talk about sears
ultimate ability exhibit sierra creates
a sphere of micro drones that reveal the
location of fast-moving enemies or
enemies firing their weapon within the
sphere this was also nerfed in the patch
increasing its cooldown from 90 to 120
seconds and also reducing its volume
generally speaking the alt was never
really the problem here it was his wall
hack ability and his heel and revive
interrupts that really gave people
nightmares and widely speaking they
still exist post nerf sir will still be
able to stop the likes of a loba from
teleporting using their tactical or an
octane using their stim others have
pointed out the hypocrisy of respawn who
nerfed bloodhound's three second scan
but still allows to retain his eight
second scan that does so much more now
there's a common theme when we look at
busted characters from other games it's
not necessarily the numbers that are the
problem it's the characters kit itself
you can add a few seconds to a cool down
here lower some damage numbers there but
what if the very essence of a character
and the utility it brings
is just busted this is what they did
they practically put bloodhound's q as a
passive for seer
and thought that wasn't going to be
broken at all i'm telling you the nerf
of
that character has like
it's not gonna do anything because the
like the base concept of seer is broken
unless they change like his kit
he's always going to be broken like apex
basically just themselves for
introducing a
character
where it's practically impossible in my
opinion to
make him not
op and nobody playing him is the last
thing respawn wants it's the same thing
with a lot of other free-to-play games
companies make a lot of money from
selling skins especially on new
characters like sear at the moment sir
is less than a month old sure he's
busted and a lot of people hate playing
against him but that's exactly why a lot
of people like playing him this guy is
different man he's like a bloodhound on
steroids seer has this heartbeat passive
where you basically can always have a
ridiculous amount of information by
being able to see up to a certain amount
of yards away of where opponents are
just by aiming in according to apex
legendstatus.com despite a 36 percent
drop in popularity sia is still the
number three most played legend in the
game behind octane and wraith he's still
really really popular and as long as a
lot of people are playing him and buying
his skins respawn are unlikely to make
the sweeping changes that some people
are calling for but let's take a look at
the bigger picture here apex legends
seems like it has a lot of momentum
right now it's popping off on twitch and
big names are helping to grow the player
base over the past few months we've had
massive streamers like nick marks tim
the tapman tifu and closey playing more
apex than warzone and bringing their fan
base to the game with them apex legends
is more difficult than warzone
it's aiming and shooting just like
warzone's positional just like warzone
it's awareness just like warzone all
those things across the board oh and
those things are also in fortnite okay
we're talking battle royale right now
um
but apex has abilities super [ __ ]
abilities and [ __ ] and i think that's a
big caveat that you can't ignore i mean
the abilities the the timings you'd
imagine that respawn and ea's number one
priority here is to keep this momentum
going there's a lot of people playing
the game there's a lot of people talking
about it they want people excited for
the new content they release these nerfs
to see seem like a bit of a compromise
with the community they've weakened him
a bit but as we talked about earlier in
the video it might not be enough however
others such as streamer sniped down who
has played a lot of sear since release
think that these nerfs may be enough to
crack his dominance in ranked going
forward you think sir is still good
snipe do you feel nerf i definitely feel
the nerve for sure i think in comp will
be more viable than in ranked
yeah
i actually i think like the ranked nerf
is
semi-significant like i think
bloodhound's probably better than him in
ranked i have no mobility like there's
not like i know i had no ability before
but like so we've talked a lot about sir
as an individual character but many
people have pointed out that c is just
the tip of the iceberg when it comes to
talking about the reveal meta for season
10 the meta has been pretty much defined
by characters who can scan and reveal
enemies legends who can do that have
quickly risen to the top of competitive
play and there's no finer example of
that than cyr and that's not surprising
given how good bloodhound has been
across the game's existence and the
patch does address some of that wider
problem as john larsen put it real time
info through geo is extremely powerful
in a shooter he also ended his twitter
thread by saying sir has opened their
eyes to what sort of information can be
communicated through scans a real-time
silhouette for x seconds is different
than tracking footsteps or the health
bar or the heartbeat passive there are
many axes we can explore and i know
sears emergence has expedited the
process of revisiting the oppressive
parts of the reveal meta to introduce
more options and counter play as far as
release strength see goes we miss the
mark players should never feel the need
to pick a legend weapon for an entire
season just to compete thankfully we're
a live game and we can iterate on things
while we can't solve the pain point of
the reveal meta in a hotfix i'm looking
forward to jamming out longer term
solutions with the rest of the design
team this seems like a hint that cyr may
see further changes in the future the
question is will there be enough to keep
people happy or will we be right back
here with another video if he continues
to dominate the game
and that way you'll never miss a video
just like this cheers
you're an apex legend mate
your name's legend
god i'm so old
you're an apex legend mate
why do i do it no one forced me to write
that you know i literally wrote that
knowing it would just be me that i had
to say